i read your book about the boobs yeah
that was bills i wrote that one in two
hours no way
yeah i'm pretty when are you doing this
aren't you a football player
i do play football
but you don't let that define you
i don't want to be defined
i'm walking poetry this one i'm about to
read to you is about the man in my beard
the man that lives in your beard yeah i
wrote this for my daughter that way she
asked me about
my beard i could tell her that there's a
man in there should i read it like i
read to the kids yeah yeah story time
there you go thank you
there's a man in my beard i know that
sounds weird he's a lonely old man with
no wife and no kids
whenever i shower he complains about the
rain how can such a small old man be
such a big pain whenever i comb my beard
he yells get out of my yard
then he lets loose his tiny small dogs
they bark and they bark they yapping
they yap i wish someone would give my
face a really big smack now i let the
kids smack me but you can't smack me
that hard
don't backslide me
you gotta do front back slap is a pimp
slap you gotta use the front hands i'm
sorry there's different ways to slap
people where's my money yeah that's like
i don't want that
i need a front slap yeah yeah there you
go
so i want to give my face a really big
slap
i'm sorry pimp slapped you yeah you
can't pimp slap because then i can't go
back to the hood no i understand you let
that white man play football tv nice
prius yeah
lesbian val kilmer yeah
martial is about it you are incredible
you know that
but for what it's worth i agree thank
you